there's the scene in the movie arrival
where Jeremy Renner's character who's a
scientist is brought in to try to help
the military deal with alien spaceships
that have landed across the globe and in
an early version of the script he asks
if the aliens have responded to Fourier
series sent out by the humans problem is
that wasn't exactly the right math
reference well a Fourier series is a
mathematical concept but it's not like a
series of numbers so I changed that to
Fibonacci series which is in fact a
series of numbers that aliens might
actually send to us as a way of getting
our attention Phil is an astronomer and
a science blogger and he's also part of
the science and entertainment exchange
an organization that connects creators
in Hollywood with scientist script
advisors they set up a phone number for
screenwriters like arrivals Eric Heisler
who want their scientific references to
sound right here's one of the things
that I wanted to make sure to do with
this movie and that's not to be
embarrassed about
complicated ideas not to be embarrassed
or ashamed of hard science that you know
these are the words and the terms that
people in this position would be sharing
with each other
Phil's advice to use Fibonacci added
that extra bit of credibility and you
know I didn't really think much of that
but then you know what you go see the
movie hey jeremy renner actually says
that the respondents anything new shapes
patterns numbers about you and I'm not
cheating my wife like yeah pointing
plenty of the screen pointing pointing
could be fun yet yeah there's a lot of
really bad science and TV and movies I'm
getting cats there's bad computer
science bad geology bad physics so in
2008 the Office of Communications at the
National Academy of Sciences launched
the science and entertainment exchange
here's how it works you call the number
you describe your question and then the
team filters through their database of
2400 scientists and engineers to put you
in touch with the right person they
estimate that they've done between 1700
and 1800 consultations since they
started that includes almost every
Marvel movie and to 2017 Oscar nominees
a lot of times the consultation boils
down to changing a line to include a
scientific concept in early discussions
for the 2011 Thor movie producer Kevin
Feige needed a way to represent the
rainbow
rich that reaches between earth and the
realm of the gods in Norse mythology so
he met with Sean Carroll a physics
professor who later paraphrased their
conversation and a blogpost Carroll
suggested they described the bridge as a
wormhole whyyyy didn't want to do that
because it sounded too 90s well there is
this thing called the einstein-rosen
bridge einstein-rosen bridge what is
that Einstein Rosen bridge is the
technical term for a wormhole they said
we love einstein-rosen bridge listen to
the dialogue in the movie and you can
hear where they added in the concept of
an einstein-rosen bridge a nice town
Rosen bridge is a theoretical connection
between two different points of space
wormhole but the team's focus isn't just
about what characters are saying it's
also about who is saying them in the
original Thor comics Natalie Portman's
character Jane Foster is a nurse the
physics professor who consulted the
filmmakers argued that it would make
more sense for the plot if she was a
physicist studying the wormhole that
brought Thor to earth and for the
exchange that sounded like the perfect
opportunity to break down gender
stereotypes we love nurses but we also
really love the idea of a strong female
character who is an astrophysicist so
the writers changed it there's a
connection two years later that
character was the focal point of a
contest twisted by Marvel in the science
and entertainment exchange where young
women interested in STEM careers could
interview female scientists in the
exchanges database for a chance to tour
laboratories and film sets we we are
very concerned with the way that
scientists are portrayed on screen you
know we want them to be I mean you
always want them to be the hero right
that's the the best thing and a main
character is fantastic but we want to
see women we want to see people of color
and we want to see them woven into the
fabric of the everyday life that you see
on screen since 1983 repeated studies
have shown that when children are asked
to draw a scientist they overwhelmingly
draw old white men children usually cite
film or cartoon characters as their main
source of inspiration and in the
original research children drew these
stereotypical characteristics more and
more frequently as they grew older
scientists had another image issue in
Hollywood - a survey of over a thousand
horror movies
distributed in Britain between 1931 and
1984 found that scientists and their
work were the villains of 41 percent of
films scientists were the heroes less
than 1% of the time in the decades since
then perceptions of science have gotten
better
an analysis of over 3,000 interviews on
public opinion about scientists found
that American adults in 2001 were much
less likely to hold negative stereotypes
about scientists than they were in 1983
and they were much more likely to
believe that a science career was a good
choice for their children or for
themselves I mean people do learn from
film and television whether you want
them to or not we often refer to it as
an accidental curriculum one of the most
talked-about examples of that is what's
called the CSI effect the idea that
chart-topping crime shows increased
interest in forensic science but also
spread a lot of misinformation about the
field
CSI didn't just launch a franchise it
created a false impression when it comes
to solving crimes
researchers in 2010 found that watching
the show is associated with perceptions
of DNA evidence as much more reliable
than it actually is
the exchange wants to mobilize that kind
of effect and hopefully make science
more understandable and more accessible
for everyone
[Music]